Hey YouTubers , it's Charlie!
So this is going to be my Q+A for Arrow and The Flash this week
Thank you everyone that submitted questions
There was actually a lot of comic book things that happened in The Flash episode
and a couple of really big twists that we need to talk about from Arrow.
A lot of you asked about the CW Fan-Talk too
I don't know if there are going to upload the video anywhere
It seemed like everyone in international countries had trouble watching it
So I'll see if there is any work arounds if I ever do something like that again
So let's get to some Arrow/The Flash craziness
General spoiler warning from episodes 10 of The Flash and Arrow
If you haven't seen them yet
So here we go
Question N.1
DeadpoolPie (that is an awesome name)
*Comment On Screen*
So that's actually a really good statement
I think that they'll answer how they brought him back in the next episode or two
I mean we'll find out really quickly but I think the real big question is going to be
what is he going to do now that he is back
and just to explain the falling off the cliff thing
I know a lot of people were wondering why didn't every bone in his body smash
Stephen Amell implied in a couple of interviews that maybe something broke his fall
and we just didn't see it like the way they cut it.
So just assume he fell hard enough to knock him out cold
And leave him the point of death but not so hard that every bone in his body was smashed to dust
Question N.2
Lots more Ollie stuff
So Akba asks
*Comment On Screen*
Yeah , so if you remember the episode that he had
with Katana , they talked a lot about what's going on up top
like a very meditative exploration of his psyche.
So I think we'll get a lot of that.
Maseo said that he asks Katana to come to wherever it is they are
to bring him (Oliver) back to life.
The way they cut the episode makes it seem like they're moving in real time
So y'know whatever three days that its been they could have jumped around with time a little bit
so we don't know how long he was out cold
What I'm really hoping is that they explain it in some way so that he
gets to actually be dead for that period of time that he was out.
It'll be really interesting to see like what's going on up in his head
like if he and Katana do some crazy meditation like they did in the previous episode.
Onto Question N.3
So , K2002ish asks...
*Comment On Screen*
That's actually a good thought
I don't know if they're going to kill Merlyn off this soon
I mean , John Barrowman feels like one of the anchors of the show
I mean , he's a really big character
It is interesting to think about when he is going to start calling himself Green Arrow.
Sidestep to Laurel , she is Black Canary.
Like the writers have said she is not THE Canary , she is BLACK CANARY.
So if she's getting the full name , maybe Oliver's full name is right around the corner.
Maybe part of his death and resurrection process is upgrading himself to Green Arrow from just The Arrow.
Back to life with a brand new personality
What I really liked to see is them (the writers of the show) hold off on the Green Arrow
name until before the series finale
and then like in the series finale , they'll let Batman come on the show
and induct him into the Justice League.
Question N.4
Steven Foster asks...
*Comment On Screen*
So it's totally possible you could see other people from the DC universe.
Or previous versions from the DC uinverse popping up on Arrow.
It's just a question of budget like it costs a lot of money to get those actors on the show
and schedules have to line up
I think I said during my Arrow review that the Ted Grant character
The actor playing him got cast in another show
Someone had asked Marc Guggenheim if Black Canary was going to have a romance with him
this year and he said that was the plan but because the actor got cast on another show
then it was a no-go , they probably weren't going to do it.
So most of the time bringing the actors on a show and trying to use them a lot
just doesn't work out for a variety of reasons.
Mark Hamill on The Flash is actually an example of it working though.
When it worked truly well.
He's going to be playing the older version of The Trickster
like his character from the original Flash TV series.
I'll talk more about that whenever we get to that episode , it's like several several weeks away
Question N.5
JackDiCarlo asks...
*Comment On Screen*
I totally agree with your logic , I just I feel like DC and Warner Brothers wouldn't let them do Batman characters that big
The writers have said a couple of times that they're just , flat out not allowed to reference Gotham City
or Metropolis , like there's certain places that are just off limits
So a lot of Batman characters they can't use but they did get to use Ra's Al Ghul so it's always possible
Part of the problem is that they are starting a new Teen Titans live action series , I mean it's just called Titans.
It's going to have Nightwing so that Robin is obviously off limits
because of that they may make all of the other Robin's off limits.
Gotham is supposedly going to be doing The Graysons but it'll be doing The Flying Graysons
So if you want to see any Robin's the closest you'll get is probably get as far as we know now is Gotham.
Question N.6
Geoffrey Gibson asks...
*Comment On Screen*
I can't remember if the producers said it so I don't want to make any big theories about them teaming up
I do vaguely recall them talking about Malcom Merlyn fighting with Oliver.
Not necessarily in like regular team-up but them VS Ra's al Ghul type situation
Because right now Ra's al Ghul still wants Merlyn and he just killed Oliver so they still have to ressolve that plot.
Episode 15 is called Nanda Parbat so something big is probably going to be happening inside Nanda Parbat.
There was this interesting interview that John Barrowman did where he talked about Merlyn's character
this season and how he views himself ,  like he views himself as the protanganist like any vain chracter would they'd always be the center of their own story.
But he kinda came off as he was just describing Merlyn as viewing himself as the good character.
Trying to do some good things.
I don't know if that'll amount to atonement or anything like that
that could lead to him fighting off Ra's al Ghul with Oliver.
That's just one of many possibilities but I'll post that link to that John Barrowman interview , he talks a lot about Merlyn.
Question N.7
So we're actually mostly getting to Flash questions now so we're onto Flash stuff.
Nadeem asks...
*Comment On Screen*
Yeah , I definitely think they will , I mean they have most of the core Rogues already either they've already cast them or we've already seen them on screen.
I think part of the reason they might be holding off on Mirror Master is because of the way his powers work
like they want to The Flash phasing through objects before they have other characters do it.
It's like they're slowing ramping up the craziness in terms of powers.
There's no way they're going to get to every single rogue from the comics so season 2 you'll probably see some Rogue characters that you did not see in Season 1
Grant Gustin was actually suggesting that time travel could really alter season 2
But I think that'll be more of a flashpoint situation
Where the Reverse Flash does something crazy in the finale this season and then The Flash has to fix it in season 2
That's just him (Gustin) speculating , they haven't even started working on season 2 yet.
Arrow just starting breaking the story for episode 20 , I think The Flash is a little bit ahead of them but they'll both have 23 episodes in the season
So both of them haven't even starting writing their finales yet.
Question N.8
ozayevabale asks
*Comment On Screen*
Okay , well like I said , I mean it doesn't follow real-world logic
Really when you're thinking about why characters do things
1) Either they're trying to replicate a panel from the comics
In this case they were
It was actually this panel right here they were trying to duplicate this from the comics
It was just done for dramatic effect
Stephen Amell has talked about this issue on Arrow like with the way they do things
He said they're N.1 goal is to make interesting TV
Sometimes that means bending the rules of logic
Question N.9
Scott N asks...
*Comment On Screen*
So , yeah , you're just saying how all of the other comic book shows don't have as many A list characters
They actually, well we have , the Supergirl show coming , they just announced Melissa Benoist is going to play Kara Zor-El.
And then they have Teen Titans , Nightwing, I guess you could look at Nightwing as a Green Arrow level character.
At some point , there will be so so many characters on television that , yeah, some of them will have more power than the others.
I know a lot of people were actually wondering about those shows
I will be doing videos from those shows whenever they come.
I might do some Supergirl videos in the near future , just because they cast the lead , they're finishing the pilot , they have a series commitment
So we will get episodes ever if they do end up cancelling it or if it does great regardless.
It's like a Gotham situation with Supergirl.
Whenever they were conceiving Gotham , whenever they were making the show.
FOX ordered a certain amount of episodes upfront.
Even before they saw the pilot.
It's kinda the same deal at CBS , I mean it's not exactly the same , fingers crossed they finish the pilot by Comic Con so they might air the pilot at Comic Con
Question N.10
Carlos Farina asks...
*Comment On Screen*
Well he has the device now so presumably he doesn't need Grant Gustin (The Flash) to travel through time.
So Harrison Wells actually seems like he genuinely likes Barry Allen
He doesn't secretly hate him.
In the comics , Eobard Thawne actually admired Barry Allen as The Flash.
Before he became Professor Zoom.
What ended up happening is that he traveled back to Barry Allen's time but kinda missed the mark
Went to The Flash museum and then found out that he was destined to become the Reverse Flash.
And it drove him crazy.
So I'm wondering if , yes , Harrison Wells is Eobard Thawne admires Barry Allen in the future so come back in time to help him fix the future.
Which another Reverse Flash has messed up.
If anyones going to do any messing up of any timelines , I think it'll be Eddie Thawne's Reverse Flash whenever or however he gets powers.
They're really mixing and matching story-lines from Wally West's era and Barry Allen's era.
Harrison Wells keeps staring at that paper , I think he keeps looking to see if the headlines change.
I think he wants to fix the future at least achieve some specific outcome and he wants Barry to fight whatever that crisis is.
Question N.11
Al Renshaw asks...
*Comment On Screen*
So , I do think that Harrison Wells had something to do with it but he's said that the military came and took all of their equipment the next day.
Jason Rush said
So I think it also could have been Clancy Brown's character , if you remember he was obessed with medi-humans and he has worked with Harrison Wells previously
So of the two people it could be , either Harrison Wells doing something a little more sinister or General Eiling.
Question N.12
Giftofa asks...
*Comment On Screen*
Well , some of them , like half and half situations , some of them have the guns , some of the weapons and some of them have full blown powers.
Like if you remember Weather Wizard from Episode 1 , obviously his brother is going to become the new weather wizard but he had medi-human powers
I think for now , they're going to go with the classic versions of the characters although I do think we will see more medi-human rogues show up especially in season 2
Question N.13
Razmw asks...
*Comment On Screen*
So you're talking about Caitlin Snow getting captured like damsel in distress stuff
Yes , I think we'll see less of that in the future , I think Caitlin Snow will be a lot more capable
I think it was all by design , just so that they could get The Rogues VS The Flash moment at the end of the episode.
Arrow is a good example on where I think they're going to get to , I think Caitlin will get to Felicity territory
where she might not be the strongest character in the world but she's very smart and resourceful so she'll get herself out of jams in the future.
You'll just see more damsels so to speak saving themselves.
Question N.14
Tresor asks...
*Comment On Screen*
So that's true in the comics , they're talked a bit about that during Flashpoint in that movie too if you saw the animated movie.
I don't know if the show's going to address that , I hope they do
I think we're a couple of steps away from that and I think Barry Allen first has to learn who Harrison Wells really is , the Reverse Flash.
And then at some point Harrison Wells will explain to Barry Allen what the SpeedForce is and how it works
A much broader explanation of how his powers work and what he is capable of.
And more along those lines , The Flash will be time travelling this season
They said that the first time he does will be completely by accident and will be because of something the new Weather Wizard does.
Like he causes Grant Gustin (The Flash) to accidentally  time travel
I have no idea how that's going to play out but I love the idea of accidental time travel.
They said that whenever they do it , it'll be both funny and really sad which sounds like a perfect combination to me.
Question N.15
TARDISGUY asks...
*Comment On Screen*
So , as of now Barry Allen has absolutely no idea what's happened to Oliver.
The way they said on The CW FanTalk , the writer of The Flash said , that they're kinda keeping their story-line seperate for now
There will be a new cross-over in episode 18 , Ray Palmer's going to go on The Flash to get some parts for his ATOM suit
They haven't said whether or not they're going to openly acknowledge Oliver's death on The Flash on coming episodes but I think that they will find out at a certain point.
If not before,  then definitely during that cross-over episode.
And that actually reminds me becuase Ray Palmer is going to S.T.A.R Labs to get gear for his ATOM suit , it also means he might get to shrink this season.
If there going to try and spin that character off into his own show , The Atom , they're probably going to show him off doing as many awesome things as possible just to get people excited
No confirmation on shrinking though , I think they're going to hold that close to their vest.
Thank you so much everyone for submitting questions , these are always a tonne of fun to do.
And huge Thank You to all of you guys that have been submitting fan-subs for all my videos so far (No problem Charlie)
I actually did like a screen-cap video so you can see everyone that has done one so far.
You guys have no idea how much this has helped me , so all of you that have submitted fan-subs totally earn a high-five the next time I'll see you guys at a convention
I will be at Star Wars celebration , definitely Comic Con  , maybe Wonder Con
So don't forget next week Arrow is Midnight City , the next part in the Canary Trilogy.
Lots of shit going down in the glades
The Flash is going to be doing Pied Piper and I think he's actually suppose to be in a couple of episodes so his arc will cross-over multiple episodes
So just in case you guys haven't seen it yet
You can click here for my Arrow episode 10 video
And click here for my Flash episode 10 video.
Thank you so much for watching so I'll see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!